[Music]
uh put it together for brian and charles
the most freaking hilarious
i can't stop imitating charles to rachel
by going front front front front stop
staying front
um so please welcome our guests
all the way from the uk from the phone
brian and charles we have the director
um
and i always forget i knew every i know
everybody's names and i always forget
them right at this moment director jim
archer
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we've just been talking about what
they've been doing
um on their visit to los angeles
and um it's pretty interesting story
is it is it
going to a lot of fancy places that i've
never been before the tower bar oh yeah
we're just sort of you know uh soaking
it up
where are you set to go after not
mondrian but um
this feels private
[Music]
just sounds fun and i'm jealous because
i never go out anywhere
um so this
film started out as a short
that in 2017 that you all worked on
um do you want to talk about
um
what what were the original ideas was
for what inspired
brian and charles
um so i'd been performing as brian on
the stand-up comedy circuit
and he was
he was like the world's worst comedian
so i'd go on and tell
bad jokes
uh because i wasn't very good at
actually writing good jokes
and uh
and sometimes it would go really well
and sometimes i'd be the most hated
person in the venue and um that's when
it was at its best yeah yeah
and um
is this in wales or is this like in
london this is everywhere around the
country
yeah yeah and um
and then um
about 10 years ago i started an internet
radio show
where he was then the world's worst
phoning host
um
there's a theme here yeah yeah yeah you
can probably sense it by my anecdotes
and um so people would skype in and uh
as brian had struggled to converse with
them
and then one one night this guy skyped
in um
but you were too shy to i was yeah not
anymore
sorry loves the limelight
and yeah give it give it grandma
applause
for being shy ten years ago
and uh
so instead of talking to brian he used
this um rupert used this um
software and one of the voices he used
was charles it really made me laugh
and we created this relationship so i'd
be chatting to charles
and i'd have to wait 10 seconds for a
reply because he'd be tapping away on
the keyboard
yeah you could hear the tap yeah but
you'd feel the silence and go tap tap
tap tap tap it is the voice that you
used that night the same that you yeah
yeah it was called charles yeah yeah and
then that night you do the voice of
charles yeah yeah traditionally yeah
yeah this is the guy
[Music]
but then he asked me that night didn't
you what's your surname i don't know why
i just said petrescue yeah and they're
stuck so yeah he was born that night
there's not a lot of thought gone is
this
um
genuinely
and uh and then chris was chris
isn't here who's in
the box he's in charles he was listening
one night and enjoying it
and thought i want to bring charles to
life so i want to build this thing
and um so he built charles like within
nine minutes
using a cardboard box and uh
am i talking loads no i love it
i feel i'm going you come alive
i feel like it's a bit too much but
come on jim
no i don't know you this is this is i
don't i'm not here at the moment
and um so uh chris bought this litter
picker-upper and stuck it to the
mannequin head
and then we did it live
as a live show brian
charles with rupert at the back voicing
charles and
so chris plays
charles physically yes
and then we sort of it comes
how was chris involved with you lot
because yours was like a one-man show
how did chris get involved with
uh
he was just a friend of ours wasn't he
on the comedy scene and
yeah it was just a voice before that he
decided to make it look like that so
it's all his fault
yeah
and then we kind of ran out of steam
doing it live
um
so we thought let's try and immortalize
them and make a short stick on youtube
no one's going to watch it
and move on to the next project
and then sort of people didn't tell me
that but yeah yeah
yeah jim can you make this short
no i'll watch it
but we we'd seen jim's work and he'd
done something i was going to watch
jim's work
i don't want to see him jim's work
except us
and then that's when we got you involved
doesn't it
loved what he does this whole q a is so
inspiring
no it seriously is because
when you do a lot of q and a's you find
out
people's inspiration comes from the most
unusual places a lot of the time it was
they weren't sitting around trying to
find an idea they were
or they were forced to come up with
something that's that's what happened in
my q a from last night it's like
we promised a short i gave myself only
48 hours to do it i did it and that's
how
yeah
so you were forced into inspiration what
was it what was that for
marcel the show oh i love that yeah
which we showed last night oh cool
that's killed the room well
thanks everybody for coming thanks guys
go watch marcel the show
so
do you
talk about turning this
into
how did you decide that you were going
to
turn it into tuned short into a feature
did somebody approach you and want to
turn it into a feature yeah uh yeah we
saw me when we shot the show um
we enjoyed making it and like and we
thought like maybe it could
have it could be longer but like we
didn't actually think anyone would want
to see that so
we uh sort of didn't really think about
it much more than that so it wasn't
until the short came out and
it kind of blew up on the internet
straight away like we put on the
internet straight away and suddenly
people yeah people
liked it and uh did the short play
around at festivals too it did
eventually yeah but i i've done
festivals before with
with one of my shorts i just feel like
the kind of process of doing that is a
bit long and kind of
unnecessary weight and this sort of
proved that point is like just put on
the internet and then like you get a
better reaction we got like a staff pick
at vimeo and like and it all picked up
on youtube so like it was it was that
was nice um but yeah so it wasn't until
like for a rupee usa to film for
yeah i was working with uh ollie madden
in my in a sort of tv show and we'd
literally just put it online that week
and i said do you want to have a look at
this he was just about to go to film
four and then he sort of called us a
week later he said you want to do a
script to this i was like okay
yeah so yeah it was never we planned
yeah it wasn't until he was like i
believe this could be a feature film
that we we also believe that i guess
yeah
so turning this
um into
into the feature version
um did you script everything out uh joke
wise that brian and charles say or do
you did you allow for like some improv
yeah um it was scripted uh
but there would be
um scenes where i think this is right
where for instance where brian takes
charles out to town
and they walk out to the van charles
wants to get in the front i'm pretty
sure there was no dialogue there it was
just was that where we invented that in
the day did we because yeah because when
we had like charles
was meant to sit in the back yeah and
then we realized we couldn't see him in
the back because this the that's exactly
impossible no it wasn't physically it
was like it was like the back windows
were blacked out so we couldn't shoot
through the window
so we're like right well he has to sit
in the front
but that doesn't make sense for the
story because he's trying to take him
into town and know and see him so
just literally like okay
david and chris just improvise the scene
where charles is adamant about sitting
in the front my favorite scene yeah my
favorite scene and i was honestly so
friendly front yeah i i laughed so much
doing that so we did we did a couple of
scenes where it was like like fully
improvised but i guess also when we do
it like
we always do like we always do script
takes so you do like the first take or
two is script and then just slowly
as it moves on becomes more and more
improvised as you sort of
either feel like you've got it or you
just play with it more so how did you
sort of uh come up with
this
conflict well two things
um how did you choose the device of
someone's making a documentary about
them but we never know who exactly or
why
uh so yeah
that question first um how did you
decide on the documentary format
mockumentary well we didn't sure i never
really questioned that short it just
sort of made sense for that story
sort of 10-page script but like we sort
of thought about not doing it for the
future um
but
then we've sort of realized how much you
get from it like especially for those
first 15 minutes where brian is by
himself
and the sort of what you expose about
him and his character by the way he sort
of
talks to cameron is lying to you and is
sort of you can he's saying one thing
but meaning another i just think that
just adds so much more
um and also the sort of cinematically
like what we could do with it like
advancing the documentary
advancing sort of mockumentary style and
making it more like a modern documentary
um
but
yeah i've already forgotten what your
question was but
well my next question is so what's a bit
different from the short is that um
charles is sort of going it sort of
becomes a coming of age tale he's going
through puberty
um
how did you come upon that idea of
uh this is what's going to cause the
conflict between
that
late on in the writing process um
and i at the time of writing my eldest
i've got three boys my eldest was sort
of 14 i think 13 14.
and uh yeah you know
well that makes sense yeah
and uh unbelievable yeah like he uh he
was really embarrassed of me which is
fair enough so are you actually
absolutely horrible we're all about it
yeah i know you are but this is about
myself i'm actually very proud of you
you're doing so well tonight thank you
and um
your boys would be proud as well yeah
so you had
you had literal children real children
going through the same things at the
same time yeah and they would see that
um
there are scenes in the film that
absolutely taken from my own life and my
my eldest boy is now 20 came to watch
the premiere in london last sunday
and uh like he would never have come
with me four years ago but now he loves
being with me
and uh but he was watching it and he was
kind of leaning into me going oh my god
dad that's that's that happened yeah i
know that's us yes so yeah and hopefully
that gave the film
grounded the film and gave it some truth
and yeah
yeah that part of it felt very universal
of
the rebellion against
the dad figure of brian
did you sort of so when you had written
this was it pre-pandemic did you know
you were going to have themes that were
kind of overlapping
with the pandemic the you know isolation
and loneliness
of brian and
no not until that's just coincidental we
were ready we were gonna film and then a
week before we were we're on the recce
in north wales when they announced
lockdown and so we had to stand down so
yeah it's just coincidence
yeah
and we thought we thought it'd never get
made then we kind of thought this would
be the first film they'll shelve
yeah yeah because like like channel 4
was like struggling that was like in the
news that they were like yeah they were
having to make calls because
cuts and stuff like that so we're like
okay well
obviously they'll get rid of us first
and then do the actual good films
and then we were one of the first ones
back up weren't we yeah we were like
months later it was like it was lovely
actually like bfi and film four who
funded us like
bfi gave us like mon that gave just
money to the crew to who like who had to
stand down just gave them like two weeks
pay just like they're a publicly funded
company so like
hats off to
you know government money
but yeah so it was uh
it was yeah their belief in the film was
kind of yeah really heartwarming
and now it's it's bbc or channel 4
that's going to become privatized right
channel 4 well yeah hopefully not up for
sale yeah yeah it's up for sale which is
really stupid
one of you guys could buy it and then
make it public again
um
what is
this word that brian says
uh i i watched it and i was like that
must be a welsh thing that i don't
understand because i'm not welsh hoopla
oopla oh do you know what i um
my wife is half french
and my mother-in-law came over
last month
and i suddenly dawned on me i was like
why do i keep saying hoopla in the film
and i s and she said it on the beach to
my
son she went hoopla
i've got it from you i said what does
that mean what does opal mean she went i
don't know
i've started using that with my kids
yeah it doesn't mean anything
it doesn't mean anything it's like let's
go it does get on with it yeah it can
mean whatever you want it's like come on
if you've got i've got i got an anime
hey go on
hoopla
there's an improv school called hoopla
don't know why
[Music]
yeah i remember um
what's that program the
move on
oh yeah the the children show heidi do
you remember that yeah and she had a uh
a friend
who's a shepherd little shepherd boy
peter and he'd go hoopla
so it's it's
some phrase that originated somewhere in
europe yeah yeah yeah
people and french people know yeah
um
all right
well i'm gonna feel free to adopt it and
actually we have a streaming service
called hoopla in the united states does
anybody use hoopla
yes it's through the la public library
so if you have a library card you can
sign up for in stream movies for free oh
wow maybe brian and charles
they're good movies
yeah there's two services called canopy
and hoopla and they're free streaming
services
so maybe brian and charles will be on
there canopy
it doesn't work
um
so when you're writing this i love this
movie because it's it's laugh out loud
funny but also incredibly poignant so
when you were writing the script
what kind of conversations you have
around
you know um so what i'm thinking of is
is the moment when brian and charles
first meet and they're in the
the living room area or wherever that is
and and charles
says hi
brian i'm your friend and suddenly
brian's just like
i think how do you that was important
craft moments like
like this isn't going to be just a
comedy like dumb and dumber this is
actually going needs to resonate with
people yeah i'm sort of not interested
in doing those comedies really just
i kind of want to
feel that sadness and truth and
and that was improvised at that moment
yeah that line was yeah yeah and then
your response yeah yeah me hiding
on the stairs behind that room yeah yeah
it was one of those things where it's
almost like oh this feels a bit on the
nose in the moment like oh just saying
it but just then david's kind of
reaction was just like
yeah i've got a friend just you weren't
expecting him to say that so it really
felt very honest of like but yeah we
were so interested in making a
a film that was like
yeah had all this kind of emotional
depth to it beyond just being because
it's like you know on the surface is
really dumb like it's a washing machine
in a mannequin's head
and he like becomes friends with it like
that doesn't make any sense
and i love that but also
an absolutely square shaped cardigan
yeah very square very square but like a
cardigan in the bow tie but like but
it's a it's a it's almost funnier to
like treat that incredibly seriously but
also like just yeah it's
yeah we wanted to
sort of
be able to connect with it and
i think i saw something written that
suggested they thought that that brian
might be on the autism spectrum was that
anything that you thought about when you
were writing it
no
no
no not at all no
um
he's just a
you know a lonely pleasant guy he tries
you know tries to be positive and he's
just a bit awkward around people bit shy
so no
i mean he might be but it's not it
wasn't a sort of conscious decision
will there be a sequel to brian charles
start filming next week yeah we're here
we haven't written it yet but is it no
can you really believe that
no we'd love to you kind of set it up
really well for a sequel yeah we get
awesome on that train it's kind of yeah
it's weird that we get asked that so we
do get asked that a lot if there's a
sequel which i don't like i don't
imagine most films get asked that but
uh i mean people have to watch it and
just i mean it needs to sort of justify
it financially first of all yeah we've
made a sequel to a film no one watched
but
uh
but yeah i mean there's definitely more
story to tell if it happens but also i'm
kind of very happy
with how we left it and i i i've sort of
feel like it's it's done
but if it makes i wonder
oh okay fair enough
new director i think
[Music]
if you get a call inviting you guys
through your next project to write
something for the marvel cinematic
universe
have we been is that an automatic ass if
you got one
what if if we got asked
i don't know i don't think i'll be very
good at that i don't i don't don't
really watch those films but i think
i'll be good
[Music]
what would your character be called
david
i don't think you can make up your own
character in the marvel universe if
you're writing it you can write yourself
in mr buttons
mr buttons yeah doctor strange call mr
button
well thank you so much for coming first
of all thank you so much for making this
film which i saw it in sundance in
january and it just i really needed a
film like this to like lighten me up and
just make me love life again so thank
you so much for making it
thanks thanks for enjoying it and when's
this come out
tomorrow
tomorrow
well please give a hand for brian and
charles and our guests
thank you for coming thanks guys thanks
very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you